Tucker Carlson is very concerned about a
floating space vagina that is not a
headline that I would have guessed two
days ago I was going to be giving you
today
this is the epitome of everything is
scary I'm going to explain right-wing
fear-mongering to you with a segment in
which Fox News propaganda's Tucker
Carlson is afraid of a Turkish floating
space vagina
um what am I talking about okay here's
the deal in Turkey there was a cloud
okay the cloud
to some people looked like a vagina
and some of you will say well David
really it's a vulva the vagina is inside
we all know what I'm talking about okay
we're using the colloquial term that is
usually used please OB gyns uh don't
write to me about this
it was really not like a huge deal it's
just a cloud I mean quite literally it's
a cloud but Tucker has to fear Monger so
he does a segment saying this is really
a problem this is not normal take a look
at this you may have seen pictures of
the very strangely shaped object that
appeared in the Skies over turkey yeah
what is that exactly it's not normal no
matter what they tell you
plus tomorrow uh millions of
church-going Christians in America still
vote for the Democrat yeah he was moving
on to his next scary story that there
are Christians who vote for Democrats
maybe blame the vaccine would be a
takeaway all right so listen this is
it's so stupid but this is very very
instructive and I'll explain to you why
whether it's about big things or small
things the right relies on
fear-mongering tactics to gain support
and to push their agenda forward if
there's a specific person to blame even
better if there's a particular group to
blame absolutely fantastic it's a
strategy that fear creates a sense of
urgency we need to know what to do now
we need to know who is subjecting us to
this and on and on and on the space
vagina
he's using the same rhetoric he he uses
with a lot of this other stuff I don't
know that he's necessarily suggesting an
investigation he just seems confused by
it I guess in some sense but the way
that this works is you use the fear to
create the sense of urgency and to
otherize someone else to agitate people
to scare them to say well tell me what
to do please you've scared me now what
is it that I'm supposed to do and that's
the point you use the fear to get people
to take action without fully considering
the consequences and this is why
right-wing politicians will often use
fear to uh try to push for quick and
drastic changes to policies or laws guys
we don't have time to sit and think
about this and to debate it there's a
floating space vagina in Turkey we've
got to do something about it right now
now usually it's not a floating space
vagina it's immigrants or communism that
doesn't exist or Marxism that they don't
understand that isn't Marxism or
whatever the case may be but that's how
you slip changes through quickly that
aren't actually in the best interests of
the majority of people
fear can also be used to create Division
and distraction
from actual issues a floating space
vagina is not a real issue Tucker's one
hour show once you take commercials away
is probably 38 minutes or 42 if it's
like you know most corporate media shows
and every one of those minutes is going
to something
rather than something else and when you
do the space vagina thing you don't talk
about an actual issue that affects
people and lastly the fear is used to
create an US versus that mentality now
he didn't go in this direction
but the Turkish floating space vagina
could be used to make the audience
suspicious of what is it that turkey is
doing what is turkey up to exactly will
they have a floating penis soon or
whatever the case may be and it's part
of this distraction method and it fuels
all of these other techniques that I
talked about so it's such a silly
example it's a small example although
the cloud is quite large it's a small
example small scale example
of how everything leads to the exact
same rhetoric and tone and that's
another fascinating and sort of funny
thing whether Tucker is talking about a
potential nuclear war
or a floating space vagina his tone is
exactly the same which signals to people
who have this stuff spoon fed to them on
Fox news they should be reacting with
equal amounts of fear to both of the
things so it's quite sophisticated
propaganda and uh it would be better if
people were more prepared to uh defend
themselves against it
one of our sponsors today is zipx
nicotine toothpicks zipx brings you a
convenient alternative to smoking and
vaping and The Vape clouds the ashtrays
the thing in your lip that people can
see I've seen that around this is an
easier and less messy way to curb the
cravings and you can use zipx just about
anywhere zipx is available in six
flavors with two or three milligram
strength the nicotine and the flavor are
long lasting and zipx has helped
countless people kick the bad habits and
they are bad habits zipx toothpicks are
FDA registered their customer service is
second to none it is one of the most
cost effective Alternatives also check
out their B12 and caffeine toothpicks
see for yourself why so many people have
switched to zipx 2 picks you can only
get zipx online go to zipxtoothpix.com
and get 10 off with the code Pacman the
link is down below